NARRATOR: At last,
in October 19, 2005,
after three years of
excavating Tutankhamun's tomb,
Howard Carter and his team
begin to open the king's coffin.
Lifting its lid
exposes another shroud.
When Carter carefully
peels that back,
he discovers a second gild
coffin even more magnificent.
It has to be hoisted out of the
first, revealing decorations
of iridescent blue, green,
and red glass inlay.
And inside that, a third coffin.
But this one is covered with a
thick black perfumed resonance
material.
With hammering, chemical
solvents, and heat,
Carter's team
gradually cleans it.
What this reveals is incredible.
While the two outer coffins
were crafted from wood
and covered in gold, this
one is made of solid gold.
Winged goddesses
protect the king
who holds the crook and
flail, symbols of royal power.
It takes eight men to lift
its lid to reveal the most
incredible sight of all.
Tutankhamun's mummy
is covered in jewels
and crowned with an exquisite
mask of solid gold, glass,
and precious stones.
AIDAN DODSON: And colorization
really brings out something.
There is this amazing
helmet mask of solid gold
inlaid with glass.
There's this great
scarab on its breast.
There are gold hands.
There are inlaid strips
with magical formulae
all over the whole thing.
No one had ever seen this
before, a pharaoh laid
exactly as he had
been by the priests
3 and 1/2 thousand years ago.
NARRATOR: The image of the gold
mask shoots around the world.
But nowhere is its impact
greater than in Egypt itself.
HEBA ABD EL-GAWAD:
This was a very highly
emotional moment in Egypt.
The discovery was
used as a reassertion
of the Egyptian identity
and a proof of us being
the descendants of
the ancient Egyptians,
which means that
we're not supposed
to be ruled by any foreigners.
This meant that Tutankhamun
had to stay in Egypt
and it were for the Egyptians.
NARRATOR: As Carter struggles to
remove the mask from the mummy,
its beard becomes detached,
revealing boyish looks.
And here we have an explanation
of why his tomb is so small.
This is not the tomb
of an old ruler.
The remains are
of a teenage boy.
Later research suggests
he died age 19.
There hadn't been time to
finish an official tomb.
So the jumbled objects and
small tomb are explained.
It was quickly assembled for the
untimely death of a young man.